on parlait justement de musique on va en
parler également maintenant avec notre
invité il sera sur la la scène du prisme
d'Élancourt samedi à 20h30 Alex Jeffrey
qui présente le son d'Alex un seul en
scène où on voyage entre musique et
humour la mise en scène est signée est
David Sall et Alex Jaffrey qui nous fait
l'honneur d'être avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir Alex
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
Il est 18h35 on peut dire bonsoir alors
je lui disais vous êtes avec nous pour
nous parler de ce spectacle qui est
finalement un hommage à vos deux
passions que son stand-up et la musique
on va regarder tout de suite un extrait
un extrait du son d'Alex est-ce que vous
savez quel âge on les Stones quand on
additionne leur âge
vous savez non ils ont 294 ans la Tour
Eiffel en a 130 ils ont fait
2470 concerts et à la fin de chaque
concert il joue quoi
et joue ce morceau les Rolling Stones
ont joué
2470 fois ce morceau à un moment donné
tu te drogues
vous l'avez compris on y parle de
musique on y apprend des années que
d'autres sur les plus grands tubes vous
analysez aussi avec humour les paroles
des chansons comment vous est venu
l'idée de ce spectacle
je pense que j'aurais aimé avoir un prof
de musique un prof d'ailleurs en général
pas seul bonne musique qui qui me fasse
marrer parce que je trouve que les profs
qui nous font rire
et ben finalement on apprend beaucoup
mieux avec et je crois qu'il est venu de
là et qu'on m'a proposé de faire une
conférence TED vous savez un TEDx et il
y a 4 ans et puis et puis je me suis
rendu compte que c'était très sympa de
monter sur scène et de raconter
de raconter la musique un peu
différemment et le spectacle est né de
ça alors vous avez l'habitude de parler
de musique en chronique en a l'habitude
de vous voir chez Télématin vous êtes
chroniqueur l’émission de France 2
est-ce que c'est si différent de de
présenter de parler de musique en
chronique et devant un public est-ce
qu'il y a différents finalement
la durée
je rigole mais c'est vrai que la
première fois je me suis dit waouh
comment on fait pour raconter autant de
trucs le texte en souvenir et puis
finalement
vous savez c'est une sorte de marabout
de ficelle vous apprenez un truc qui
enchaîne un autre truc et puis
finalement c'est 7h30 de texte elle
glisse toute seule et après ce qui est
terrible c'est de retourner à la télé et
comme je disais ce matin aussi et il
vous dites vous racontez un truc et au
bout de trois minutes il y a un
assistant plateau qui vous faites
les fameux tamis on les connaît bien
même ici dans le 7 8 il y a un exercice
que vous préférez entre la chronique et
le one man show
c'est très différent j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer
un exemple j'ai rencontré la logiefrine
qui est le compositeur de mission
impossible et il a écrit plein de
musique de films mais c'est vrai que
mission impossible c'est le truc le plus
connu et quand j'ai demandé à la
logistique c'est quoi la différence
entre justement écrire une musique de
film ou un générique pour la télé il
fait s'il y a un accent argentin est
fait quand j'ai créé pour le cinéma j'ai
pris une lettre mais quand j'écris pour
la télé j'ai écrit un télégramme c'est
pareil
alors dans ce spectacle je disais vous
nous livrez des anecdotes de Gilbert
Montagné au Daft Punk en passant par
Booba on a écouté tout à l'heure on a
entendu tout à l'heure aussi les les
Rolling Stones avant de les présenter
sur scène on imagine qu'il y a un gros
travail de recherche notamment peut-être
dans les dans les archives que comment
ça se passe comment ça se prépare
justement le son d'Alex
comme comme la chronique que je fais
dans Télé Matin et sur internet le son
d'Alex c'est d'abord j'ai une équipe qui
m'accompagne par chance et puis et puis
après c'est c'est des années des années
et des années de recherche de lire des
bouquins c'est que moi j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à ça avant Internet je
cherchais des samples sur des vinyles
des trucs et puis un jour internet est
arrivé donc ça change la donne mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vous
pouvez échanger vous dites ah il me
semble que ce bout de musique ça vient
d'un truc de qu'on avait déjà entendu en
75 et voilà tout ça mes bout à bout ça
fait un spectacle est-ce qu'il y a une
anecdote qui vous a marqué plus qu'une
autre que vous pourriez nous partager ce
soir
un truc énorme qui est dans le spectacle
et qui marche pas mal si vous prenez la
mélodie de l'été indien vous voyez la
mélodie ça fait
ça c'est l'été indien vous prenez les
mêmes notes vous les mettez dans l'autre
sens et ça fait aller
destiné destiné on était tous les deux
destiné c'est exactement la mélodie
inverse de l'été dernier vous connaissez
l'anecdote en plateau juste petit tour
de table pas du tout bon il y a ce genre
d'anecdote et plein d'autres dans le
dans le spectacle d'Alex j'apprends ce
qui est aussi intéressant il me semble
que à la fin du spectacle où il y a une
création participative d'une musique
avec le avec le public c'est bien ça
absolument c'est ce que je propose c'est
ce que je propose à tous les tous les
spectateurs c'est-à-dire que pendant une
heure et demie
j'explique pas trop évidemment c'est
très drôle c'est pas un cours c'est pas
une Master Class ça va pénible c'est
vraiment rigolo et à la fin on met tout
tout ce qu'on a appris
je vais pas trouver le mot mais je vous
l'enverrai par SMS demain vous pourrez
utiliser demain le monde ne vient pas on
met en pratique ça y est le
pratique
on met en pratique tout ce qu'on a
appris et on écrit un tube et donc on
écrit un tube donc là par exemple samedi
on va écrire un tube voilà à Élancourt
le tube sort lundi et mercredi c'est pas
la peine d'aller bosser parce que le
public sera riche à millions vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est le principe
que ce spectacle
c'est le principe de ce spectacle on a
vu sur votre biographie vous étiez né à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine vous avez
grandi aussi dans les Yvelines ou vous
avez juste un lien avec
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine parce que c'est
votre ville de naissance c'est ma ville
de naissance je suis né à la clinique
des Tilleuls m'a-t-on dit n'existe plus
à mon grand désespoir je pensais qu'il y
aurait un mausolée avec une photo de moi
de profil comme ça mais non c'est
dommage je suis un peu triste
d'apprendre ça mais bon non non j'ai
grandi dans le 95
j'ai grandi à Pontoise et je ne sais pas
pourquoi mes parents ne veulent pas y
avoir de maternité à Pontoise donc ils
sont venus à Conflans
avec le départ 55 ans mais j'en garde un
très très bon souvenir mais est-ce que
vous avez une sensation particulière de
venir jouer devant le public de de votre
département de naissance du coup mais
oui évidemment je prépare des vannes
pour je prépare des vannes pour pour
samedi et je crois que j'espère que tu
as encore des places
ma production m'a dit qu'il en restait
mais pas pas des masses donc je dis ça
pour que ça mette la pression aux gens
pour que les les 10 dernières places ces
gens se jettent dessus comme ça vite
déplace je raconterai un truc de mon
enfance en plus exprès parce que je suis
dans le 78 bon alors vite aller sur le
site du prisme de Lancôme on va pouvoir
voir l'animation serait affichée à
nouveau vous serez donc sur la scène de
cette scène et l'en courtois samedi à
20h30 pour le son d'Alex de et par vous
et donc toutes les informations je le
disais à retrouver sur le site du prisme
d'Élancourt merci beaucoup Alex Jaffrey
d'avoir été avec nous merci c'est très
sympa merci bonne fin de l'émission je
pensais qu'on était tous les deux quand
j'ai vu le grand le plan avec tout le
monde j'aurais dit moins de conneries je
suis vraiment désolé non non il y a un
peu de monde il y a les journalistes de
la rédaction des invités aussi c'est le
principe du 7 8 c'est de mêler voilà des
différents horizons pour parler de
l'actualité du 78 c'est le principe
ça marche merci beaucoup merci encore à
vous